(laughing)
- All right Janice that's it.
Janice, Janice.
Hey, Janice.
- By the way, Chandler, I cut
you out of all my pictures
so if you want I have a bag,
with just your heads.
(audience laughing)
- That's okay.
- Are you sure, really?
Because you can make
little puppets out of them
and you can use them in
your theater of cruelty.
(audience laughing)
You know, one of two
things is happening here,
either you're seeing
somebody behind my back
which would make you the
biggest jerk on the planet,
or else you're pretending
that you're seeing somebody,
which just makes you so pathetic
I could just start crying
right here in the cereal aisle.
Happy Valentine's Day.
(audience laughing)
You love me, Chandler Bing.
- Oh no I don't.
- You seek me out,
something deep in your soul
calls me out to me like a foghorn.
Janice,
Janice.
You want me.
You need me.
You can't live without me and you know it.
You just don't know, you know it.
- Oh my God, oh my God, you have to go
- Why?
- Because Chandler still
has feelings for you.
- He does?
- Say it again.
- That's right, that's right.
And that is why you
can't stay here tonight
and probably why you
shouldn't come to the wedding.
- Feeling such strong feelings.
(audience laughing)
- I mean I realize that his feelings
may never completely go away
but you can.
- Oh, my God.
I understand, I'm so sorry, I'll go.
Goodbye Monica.
I wish you a lifetime
of happiness with him.
Chandler, you call me when
this goes in the pooper.
- I need you.
I must have you Janice Litman
Goralnik Ney Hosenstein.
(audience laughing)
- Chandler, what are you talking about?
- Now that you live next door,
we can be together every day.
Sid and Monica never have to know a thing.
- I don't know what to say.
I mean obviously we have this,
heat between us.
- Obviously.
- But I love my husband and
I know you love your wife.
I don't think we should
get this house now.
- Don't say that.
Don't dangle the dream and take it away.
(audience laughing)
- Chandler one of us has got to be strong.
- I understand.
- Although, maybe just one
last moment of weakness.
(laughing)
Have any of you ever almost?
- Does anybody want more coffee?
- Yeah, I'll take--
- Hey there's a dog out there.
- Oh Chandler sorry.
Oh Chandler sorry.
Hey Janice.
- Hi Monica.
- Okay well this was very special.
- Rach, come see who's out here.
(audience laughing)
- What's going on?
Oh my God, Janice, hi.
- Janice is gonna go away now.
(audience laughing)
- I'll be right back.
- Joey, look who it is.
- Whoa.
- Oh good, Joey's home now.
- This is so much fun.
This is like a reunion in the hall.
(laughing)
- Oh hi Ross.
There's someone I want you to say hi to.
He just happened to call.
- Hello Ross, yes that's right it's me,
how did you know?
(laughing)
- It's actually going to be just family.
- Oh wait.
You two think of me as family?
I have to ask you something
now and be honest.
Do you want me to sing Careless Whisper
or Lady in Red?
(audience laughing)
Hello Joey, our little matchmaker
I could just kiss you all over
and I'm gonna.
- If you don't do it, I will.
(audience laughing)
- Let me make sure I'm hearing this right,
you're ending this with me,
because I'm too whiny?
So you're saying, I've become so whiny
that I, annoy you,
Janice.
- Well yeah.
- Oh, my, God.
- It's me.
- Oh,
my,
God.
Oh,
my,
God.
Oh,
my,
God.
Oh,
my,
God.
(audience laughing)
- [Group] Oh,
my,
God.
- Night, night bing-a-ling.
- Night night,
Janice.
(audience laughing)